Pues básicamente seguir adelante Rusia
tiene confianza en que a pesar de los
reveses importantes que ha sufrido en el
campo de batalla concretamente tres en
este año que llevamos de guerra
finalmente conseguirá ganar un poco más
de terreno según vaya avanzando el
tiempo y provocar o a una rendición del
gobierno de algún tipo de negociación En
ese sentido es en el que ha apuntado hoy
Putin sin hablar de la negociación pero
recordando que Rusia no puede perder en
el campo de batalla porque es invencible
Javier mucha retórica antioccidentales
en el discurso de Putin no solo en lo
militares sino también en lo cultural se
agranda la brecha entre Rusia y
occidente
sea grande la brecha porque Vladimir
Putin acusado accidente de estar
avivando las llamas de una guerra global
además colocado la responsabilidad del
inicio de las hostilidades en occidente
a pesar de que él fue el que dio la
orden de invadir hace poco más de un año
y además ha recordado que es occidente
el que está intentando imponer sus
valores totalitarios Aunque en los
países occidentales lo llamen liberales
bueno incluso habló de tendencias
religiosas y de las parejas del mismo
sexo ahora en una tercera pregunta para
usted Javier Putin suspendió la
participación de Rusia en el tratado de
New Start el último acuerdo sobre
control de armas nucleares que aún
estaba vigente Qué implicaciones tiene
esto
unas implicaciones
importantes porque era como como bien
decías el último tratado que quedaba es
un tratado que limita la cantidad de
armas de armas nucleares que puede tener
cada país pero sobre todo era una base
para mantener el diálogo respecto a
control de arsenales entre las dos
principales potencias nucleares también
es un mensaje preocupante para otros
países con armas nucleares que la tienen
todavía menos razones para limitar su
proliferación y finalmente saber en
medio de las críticas recibidas durante
la invasión no cree usted que sale
políticamente fortalecido Putin tras
este discurso
Bueno eso está por ver habrá que ver
sobre lo más importante es si la
ofensiva que está preparando tiene éxito
pero desde luego que este discurso tenía
una importancia política de Cara a
plantear a los rusos que la guerra no es
un algo negociable o que se pueda elegir
o no la guerra es lo primero y la
economía va después Y en segundo lugar
colocar un mensaje de fortaleza interna
también diciendo que la economía está
aguantando a pesar de las sanciones y
que el gobierno ruso como ha explicado
hoy Vladimir Putin va a dar ayudas a los
que lo estén pasando peor